[Music]
to our other top story at this hour the
animal foundation facing tough questions
of the Clark County Commissioners
meeting today thank you for joining us
here at four I'm Kirsten Joyce and I'm
Brian Loftus now the county wants
progress on a series of promises they
say the animal foundation made to them
Victoria Saha has been closely following
this for us joins us now live from the
animal foundation with more
direct today
nation has already done instead they
want transparency and results
and we need support and partnership more
than ever before CEO of the animal
foundation Hilary gray expressing what
the shelter is going through our
dedicated and extremely hard-working
team of staff and volunteers is caring
for more than 550 animals what we
receive is a just
a multitude of those kind of complaints
commissioner jib Gibson referring to one
of the more common complaints Good
Samaritans having trouble turning
animals in at the shelter Last Summer
the open admission shelter started
requiring appointments to drop off
animals this is something that you know
we've been advised on by all of the
national organizations today it can be
possible to book same day or next day
appointments what I looked online after
the meeting Wednesday was the earliest
for adoption Returns the next available
appointment to drop off a stray animal
was next month leaving the burden to
rescue groups you leave these animals
out on the streets and they're dead they
die terrible deaths commissioner Marilyn
Kirkpatrick wants answers I only care
about Clark County and you want to tell
me about National gray also says they're
short-staffed following a national Trend
need more money you'll say that I just
am not throwing good money after bad
Clark County gives the animal foundation
more than two hundred thousand dollars a
month that's more than 2.4 million a
year that doesn't include the money they
get from the city of Las Vegas and North
Las Vegas
there was a positive note in all this
accounting Commissioners and the animal
foundation agreed that the rescue groups
can possibly get funding for the intakes
right now a majority of them just depend
on donations from the public Victoria
Saha 8 News Now